[Musique]
bonsoir
je m'appelle ilonise
et je suis là pour vous trouver le match
parfait
[Musique]
est ce que vous aimeriez faire une
rencontre improbable
une rencontre inestimable
une rencontre qui pourrait changer le
cours de votre destin
eh bien j'ai le pouvoir de faire ça ce
soir pour chacune et chacun d'entre vous
mon métier c'est d'identifier le profil
qui vous correspond le mieux à ce moment
vous en êtes de votre vie les de vous
mettre en relation avec une personne
avec qui vous allez vivre ne très belle
histoire
alors au premier rendez vous vous serez
peut-être un petit peu stressé mais
c'est normal et puis ensuite à chaque
fois que vous échangerez vous aurez
peut-être des petits papillons dans le
ventre
parfois comme dans toutes les aventures
il faudra s'accrocher
mais au fil du temps vous verrez votre
relation mûrir et le cours de votre vie
font trouvera à transformer tout comme
celui de la personne avec qui je vous
aurais mis en relation
alors oui en quelque sorte je suis une
entremetteuse
les relations je crée ne sont pas des
relations amoureuses mais elles sont au
moins tout aussi importantes
puisqu'elles ont le pouvoir de changer
le cours de votre destin
je crée des relations de mentorat
je connecte ceux qui cherchent leur voie
avec ceux qui ont trouvé la leur et ça
fait des étincelles
et avant de vous trouver le match
parfait j'aimerais qu'on se pose une
question ensemble
pourquoi est ce que les relations
humaines les rencontres sont si
importantes pour nous les êtres humains
et ben apparemment c'est une question de
survie
carrément de survie on dit que l'être
humain est un être social et c'est vrai
dès notre naissance nous avons besoin
des autres pour survivre si vous
comparez avec d'autres animaux nous
sommes les plus vulnérables à notre
naissance
je sais pas les vôtres si vous en avez
moi mes enfants quand ils sont nés ils
savaient rien faire tout seul
à six mois ils tiennent leur cuiller et
on est émerveillé
mais bon si on compare avec un bébé
antilopes qui tient debout en quelques
minutes et qui galope en quelques heures
le succès de la cuillère prend une
importance toute relative
un être humain n'est pas capable de se
lever ni même de marcher ni même de se
nourrir à sa naissance il faut toute une
communauté pour faire grandir un humain
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a un peu
de congé maternité c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça qu'on a un tout petit peu de congé
paternité
pour ça que beaucoup de parents se
sentent désemparés dans les premiers
mois de vie de leurs enfants parce qu'on
a resserré le noyau familial au strict
minimum et que c'est pas eu ni même deux
personnes qu'il faut pour élever un
enfant vient toute une communauté
alors c'est une question de survie mais
c'est aussi une question
d'épanouissement on sait aujourd'hui que
notre bonheur dépend de la qualité des
relations que nous entretenons non pas
de la quantité mais bien de la qualité
de nos interactions avec nos proches
mieux vaut compter sur trois bons amis
pour nous remonter le moral aller boire
un verre garder nos enfants qui tienne
si bien leur cuiller
que 1500 relations sur linkedin ou 39
voleurs sur instinct
autrement dit les relations humaines les
rencontres sont le socle de notre
humanité et la condition sinequanone de
notre bonheur
peut-être que comme moi vous avez des
personnes dans votre vie vous avez
rencontré qui ont changé le cours de
votre destin
moi c'est une prof que j'ai rencontré
ici à grenoble et qui m'a permis de
partir vivre en espagne quand j'avais 19
ans je suis allé en espèces
et puis en espagne j'ai rencontré une de
mes meilleures amies qui m'a donné envie
d'aller découvrir la grèce alors je suis
allé en grâce et puis là j'ai rencontré
un autre ami qui m'a donné envie d'aller
découvrir son pays l'afrique du sud
c'est un peu plus loin je suis allé en
afrique du sud et là j'ai découvert ma
vocation professionnelle qui ensuite va
emmener aux philippines beaucoup plus
long
avant de revenir en france
et sur part du début cette prof je pense
pas qu'elle l'avait prévu ni qu'elle l'a
fait exprès mais elle a changé ma vie
et mon métier depuis c'est de créer
c'est rendre compte qui vous le verrez
destin
parce que si moi j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer ces personnes à ces moments
là de ma vie ce n'est pas le cas de tout
le monde
les rencontres que l'on fait sont
largement déterminée par le milieu dont
on vient
si votre mère et chef d'orchestre
vous avez plus de chance que ses amis
soit est aussi chef d'orchestre aux
musiciens de vous intéresser à la
musique de faire des études dans la
musique et de devenir vous-même
violoncelliste ou chanteurs d'opéra si
votre père est douanier mais vous avez
plus de chance que ses amis sauter aussi
douaniers et de vous intéresser à ce
secteur et de devenir vous-même
douaniers
ou trafiquants de drogue
si on intègre une notion de classe
sociale là dedans et que la chef
d'orchestre est une cadre et que le
douanier est un ouvrier on parle de
déterminisme social
le déterminisme social c'est ce qui
expliquerait notamment qu'en france il
faut aujourd'hui six générations pour
sortir de la pauvreté
ça fait cent quatre-vingts ans
ça veut dire que si aujourd'hui en 2022
vous vivez avec moins de 1000 euros par
mois il vous faut attendre d'être en
2002 102 pour pouvoir potentiellement
gagner plus de 2300 euros par mois ce
qui est aujourd'hui le revenu mensuel
moyen
enfin ça c'est si vous êtes un homme
parce que si vous êtes une femme il
faudra vous contenter de 2000 euros mais
c'est un autre sujet
et donc s'il faut six générations pour
sortir de la pauvreté en france
aujourd'hui ça s'explique par plein de
choses mais notamment par le fait que si
vos parents n'ont pas fait d'études vous
avez quatre fois moins de chance de
faire des études vous même que s'ils
sont diplômés et donc de mieux gagner
votre vie
alors je suis pas là pour vous dire si
l'argent fait le bonheur ou qu'il faut
que tout le monde prenne l'ascenseur
social
l'important pour moi c'est pas
nécessairement d'aller plus haut c'est
d'avoir la possibilité d'aller ailleurs
comme ça on n'a pas besoin d'ascenseur
on n'a même pas besoin d'escalier il
suffit de pousser la porte et cette
porte souvent des c'est une rencontre et
puis qu'ensuite on décide si on veut
aller en haut en bas à gauche à droite
ou juste au milieu c'est pas important
ce qui est important c'est d'en avoir le
choix
alors peut-être que vous allez me dire
on ne choisit pas sa famille mais c'est
pas ça le problème le problème c'est si
on ne fréquente personne d'autre que sa
famille ou que des gens qui leur
ressemblent le problème c'est de ne pas
pousser la porte c'est de ne pas faire
de rencontre
alors ces rencontres qui sont
déterminantes pour notre parcours on
peut les laisser au fruit du hasard
ou choisir de les provoquer et c'est ça
qui m'anime au quotidien dans
l'association pour laquelle je travaille
nous créons ces rencontres par le biais
de mentorat pour accompagner des jeunes
issus de milieux modestes dans leur
réussite au pluriel
pour qu'ils puissent pousser la porte
pour qu'ils puissent faire des
rencontres et qu'ils puissent ensuite
décider s'ils veulent être en haut en
bas à gauche à droite ou juste au milieu
notre ambition en tout cas c'est qu'ils
puissent aller au bout de leur potentiel
et s'épanouir dans leur schéma nuit
alors je vous ai promis le match parfait
je vous rassure tout de suite je vais
pas faire ça toute seule
avec mes collègues on va regarder la
profession vous exercez où le métier qui
vous intéressent des études que vous
avez fait que vous êtes en train de
faire si vous souhaitez accompagné ou
être accompagné ce que vous aimez dans
la vie ben oui parce que comme on crée
des relations improbable qui a priori
serait pas possible sans nous il faut
bien qu'ils aient un minimum de points
communs entre où est votre mentor ou
votre mentor
alors le mentorat c'est quoi
le mentorat s'est créée ces relations et
ne pas les laisser au fruit du hasard le
mentorat c'est une relation entre deux
personnes un mentor et un entouré alors
dans mon association le mentor et dans
la vie active et le mentorat est un
étudiant mais dans l'absolu le mentorat
ça peut s'adresser à tous à des plus
jeunes à des plus vieux à des personnes
qui sont en recherche d'emploi qui sont
nouvelles dans une entreprise à tout le
monde le mentorat c'est la conviction
profonde que chacun et chacune d'entre
nous a quelque chose à apporter un père
l'objectif c'est d'aider le mentor et à
trouver les solutions face aux obstacles
qui vont se dresser sur son chemin mais
surtout de l'aider à garder le cap a
gardé le moral
vraiment or ce n'est pas un psy ce n'est
pas un parent ce n'est pas un prof ce
n'est pas juste un copain c'est un peu
comme un supporters qui est là aux côtés
de son mentor et envers et contre tout
un cheerleader un fan club à lui tout
seul
depuis dix ans que je crée ses relations
de mentorat j'ai vu des tas d'histoires
chamboule
martha
passionné d'art depuis toujours par
suivre ses études à 500 km de chez elle
seule puisqu'elle n'a pas réussi à
convaincre sa famille qu'elle pourrait
gagner sa vie dans ce secteur
isolement
elle rencontre son mentor qui la met en
lien avec un ami qui tient une galerie
d'art qui l'aident à trouver son premier
stage et qui lance sa carrière
aujourd'hui martha lé commissaire
priseur
et elle retourne tous les ans dans son
lycée pour dire aux plus jeunes et
surtout aux jeunes femmes qu'il faut
suivre ses rêves quand on en a
cédric étudiant en économie qui doit
travailler de nuit pour financer ses
études et payer son loyer
le rythme est trop soutenu et cédric
crack
dépression
hospitalisation
son mentor bien voir toutes les semaines
pour lui remonter le moral et changer
les idées et lui parler de l'actualité
et bien croyez le ou non mais cette
année là cédric a réussi à s'accrocher
et à passer ses parts il
m'a dit première de sa famille à se
lancer dans des études supérieures ah
oui parce que si personne n'avait fait
avant elle le disait que c'était il y
avait une bonne raison
autocensure et puis rencontre avec sa
mentor qui ne la lâche pas même quand
elle veut arrêter la prépa même quand
elle a raté ses concours même quand elle
doit envoyer quatre fois plus de
candidatures pour avoir un stage que les
autres parce qu'elle n'a pas le bon nom
la bonne adresse
aujourd'hui m'a dit est ingénieur depuis
cinq ans et elle est toujours en lien
avec sa mentor sauf que maintenant elle
parle de l'organisation du temps de ma
dit partagé entre femmes actives est
mère au foyer et mère de famille
imaginez ces trois histoires x toute une
génération je vous laisse projeté
l'impact sur notre société
alors si vous êtes plus ému par les
chiffres que par les belles histoires
fin arrive on a mesuré l'impact du
mentorat dans une association
ça donne 30 % de décrochage en moins
dans la première année d'études
supérieures à diplôme égal
on a un taux d'insertion dans l'emploi
qui est de 30% supérieur à la moyenne
une rémunération qui est de 15%
supérieur à la moyenne mais surtout un
sentiment d'épanouissement qui est de
18% supérieur à la moyenne dans le
premier emploi parce que c'est ça qui
est essentiel à mon sens indépendamment
des représentations que l'on peut se
faire des classes ou des métiers c'est
de se sentir à sa place là où on est et
aline et avec soi même
mais de mentorat c'est aussi la
possibilité de découvrir un nouveau
monde
si on reprend la théorie de la
reproduction sociale etc on a simplifié
au maximum on peut se dire que depuis
que notre naissance on évolue dans une
sorte de bulle avec ses propres codes
notre monde donc une manière de parler
une manière de prendre les repas les
habitudes culturelles par exemple chez
moi on aime beaucoup jouer ou d'un jaune
et on va faire des promenades en
montagne et on est entouré souvent des
personnes qui font le même type de
métier
d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressante c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ces bulles on les
retrouve sur internet et les réseaux
sociaux avec les fameuses bulles de
filtres qui nous suggérait toujours les
mêmes contenus ce qui nous plaise ou non
connecteraient toujours avec les mêmes
personnes celle qui nous ressemble
le mentorat c'est sortir de sa bulle
pour découvrir un autre monde avec
d'autres cadres et d'autres habitudes
par exemple moi quand je suis devenu mon
tort
eh ben j'ai découvert qu'on pouvait
vivre en banlieue lyonnaise et n'avoir
jamais mis les pieds à lyon
et j'ai découvert aussi qu'on pouvait
vivre à lyon et n'avoir jamais mis les
pieds en banlieue lyonnaise
on sait appris plein de choses
fascinantes avec mon manteau ray par
exemple moi je lui ai appris ce que
c'était qu'un tableau croisé dynamique
ou des softs qu'ils
aient lui il m'a appris ce que veut dire
à skip
et que jpp n'est plus jean pierre papin
depuis très longtemps mais j'en peux
plus et du coup j'ai aussi appris à mes
dépends ce que veut dire bout meuse
mais surtout il m'a permis de sortir un
nouveau de ma bulle et de découvrir la
sienne et puis je crois que lui aussi il
a découvert une nouvelle bulle n'avait
une nouvelle bulle avec la mienne et
puis quand on commence à avoir découvert
d'autres bulles on sent plus en
confiance pour en découvrir encore
d'autres etc et puis notre bulle
s'agrandit et au final vous verrez que
plus on découvre de nouvelles bulles
plus on apprend à connaître la sienne et
à s'y sentir bien
parce que c'est ça qui est réellement
puissants avec le mentorat c'est que
d'un côté on a un outil qui est très
simple et très concret et qui permet à
tous de s'engager à sa mesure quel que
soit son profil pour reconnecter notre
société et de l'autre c'est aussi
l'occasion de découvrir de nouveaux
mondes pour enfin revenir ce que
reconnecter avec soi même
si nous devenions tous mentor et si nous
avions tous l'opportunité d'être mentor
et à des moments clés de notre vie je
suis convaincu que nous formerions de
société plus juste plus soudé et plus
heureuse
alors vous maintenant
est ce que vous avez envie de sortir de
votre bulle et d'en découvrir une autre
est ce que vous avez envie de pousser
cette porte est de faire une rencontre
improbable
est-ce que vous êtes prêts pour le match
parfait
merci beaucoup
[Musique]